[Applause]
were you I'm very curious because I'm
curious what you were like as a child
whenever I mean at a performer who's
particularly interesting a unique I
think what was that person like as a
child were you peewee as a child to a
degree I was yeah I this will sort of
illustrate who I was as a kid I was
probably five or six years old I had a
younger sister a year younger than me I
have a younger sister year younger than
me and she got for her birthday or
Christmas or something one time she got
a little tea set which she was like look
I don't want this tea set I mean I was
mesmerized by the tea set of media I was
like you don't want this are you insane
what is it woman with you you know you
can certainly eat your tea with this
thing it was like the little cup dirty
and so I like freaked out when I saw it
I was like I'll take it you know I'll
take the tea and my dad noticed that and
my dad went like why don't we have a tea
party Paul and my dad had never said
anything like that to me before I was
like are you kidding me like you won't
have a tea party like yeah give me three
minutes you know like you know a little
kid furniture lecture chair a little
tape on stuff so I went and filled up
the teapot and set out like a little
little what he calls a sir and I'm
getting so excited just yeah and my dad
came up and he sat down on the little
chair and he did the coolest thing I
poured him a cup of I mean it was water
more than I poured him a little thing
and a little teacup and he put it up and
he blew he went that's nice and I
thought I have the coolest dad in the
world that he would like pretend like
the key
so he drank the tea down and then he
went this t is unbelievable did who made
you made the tea I was like yeah he like
he drank three cups right emptied the
pitcher right and said is there more to
because if I don't have any more team
and a freak out I have to have more tea
right so I ran filled the pitcher up
came back three more cups and only three
cups was all it took
so three more cups mmm delicious tea pop
is there any more tea yeah there's more
tea I ran and got finally after four
trips to fill up the thing I came back I
said dad no more tea I'm sorry we're out
of tea and he said what do you mean
we're out of tea I said the toilets
empty
[Applause]
[Music]
what a wonderful
go ahead have some you know III I'm just
curious I mean I know it's been a while
since you you're pee-wee Herman but have
you ever thought about getting back into
the peewee suit being peewee again you
know I just finished a peewee movie a
script do you look like you look like
you stayed in pretty good shape and and
I've been trying to slim down shed a few
pounds cuz you know we get older you
gain a little bit away right do you
think it'd fit in the peewee outfit ya
know cuz we actually we actually found a
peewee outfit ha ha this is the real
pee-wee Herman outfit we have right here
we were curious if he would fit into it
you think he could fit into it
it's gonna fit right into this David Lee
Roth can put the jacket you wanna bet
any money on yeah I bet you $800 we have
a little producer will pay it I don't
have that kind of money I haven't gained
that much weight but they were it was
tight to begin with right just really
yeah but it was a very skinny suit do
you feel yourself becoming pee-wee as
you put it on it's not about the pants
peewee is really in me yeah you know
right music
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]